[音楽]
早速ですけれども皆さん今日って買い物をされましたか
私はすぐそこのスーパーであの暑かったので水を買いました
最近皆さん買い物をして楽しんでますか
これまでに心を震わせるような買い物体験ってありますか
例えば
子供の時にどうしても欲しかったおもちゃを買ってもらってとってもうれしかったりと
か
例えば散々選んだ挙句に買ったギフトが大切な人にとっても喜んでもらえたとき
買い物って
とってもエッセン賞だと思うんです私たちって身の回りのものを全てを作り出せるわけ
ではないですよね
私は百貨店員として皆さんにですね
どうやったら楽しいお買い物体系を提供できるかということを考えています
ちょっとここで買い物ってそもそもなんだろうということを考えてみたいんですけれど
も
買い物ってなんなんでしょ
買い物って行為ですよねものを買うという行為
こうやって目的ではないまあ時にはや怪我へみたいな感じでそのものを買うこと自体が
目的関しましてしまうこともあるんですけどもまぁ基本的にはニュートラルだと私は
思っています
例えば寒くなってきたからこうと買わなきゃなーとか
例えばおなかがすいたからご飯買わなきゃなとか
あとお世話になってる人に感謝の意味をま込めたいから
ギフトを買おうかなとかただその買う目的がまあえっと先というかベースにあって
えっとをマヨはあのかうっていうことがまあソリューションになっているわけですよね
で人って言ったうんその目的みたいなものが顕在化するとソリューションのすぐ話に
なると思うんです
例えば買うことでいったら何でしょう
早く手に入れたいですとか少しでも安く買いたいとか
ショット利便性のベクトルが働き言いますよね
でじゃあ買うって何だろうって整理をすると顕在化された目的を効率的に消化をする
こと
うんこれってすべてでしょうかねぇ
私はちょっと違うと思うんですね私が買うことの価値として皆さんに申し上げたいのは
密書の a 出会いを通じてその自分の世界の認識を広げることです
で昨今も買い物ってネットでいいよねっていう風にも言われますよね
僕と聞くとすごい悲しくなるんですよで so-net かリアルかっていう二者択一
じゃなくて
ネットとリアルのまあいいところを組みたって買いもの楽しんじゃえばいいんじゃない
かって思うんです
でネットとリアルをまあ要は買うバーとしてドラフに分類をするとどうなるんでしょう
ねネットっていうのはもしかしたらもうすでに知っている価値の確認作業を誇示すると
ラブに言い過ぎかもしれませんけれど持って言えるかもしれません
デリアルって言うのはそれも含めてやっぱり3機種の出会いなんじゃないかなという
ふうに思います
ああああああ
道所の出会いがすでに知っていること基地になってその時の岩と卵事象のインパクトで
買ったりとか買わなかったりっていう行動がままれるんじゃないかなという思ってい
ます
反応が当然あると思うんですねネットだってみちろであるじゃないかただリアルのほう
が自分をコントロールがつかないまあ飲酒というか様子
が多い部分いわゆるそのセレンディピティが起こる確率っていうのは高まると思うん
ですよ
ちょっと旅でたとえますね旅でえっとまぁこんな旅自分はしたくないなと思うのが
まあせっかく旅行してある土地に入ってるのに何かガイドブックの情報を確認するだけ
みたいな
例えばピサの斜塔やっぱ傾いてよねみたいな
これこれでもいいんですけどももうちょっと残念な気がします
やっぱり旅っていうのは私が思うにやっぱり自分と異なる価値観の中に身を置いてみて
そこから生まれその予測不可能性の中で自分のその認識を広げていくことなんじゃない
かなって思っています
で買い物の話に戻ると正直あのリアルで会ってネットで買うっていうのは全然アリだと
思っていますしこれがどんどん増えていけばいいと思います
で自分の今のその仕事の立場でこんなことをちょっと入ってしまうのもなかなか厳しい
ものがあるんですけれども
一番危惧しているのが買い物っていう行為はですね
結局そう
の事前に仕入れた情報の確認作業になって今いませんかっていうことなんですね
でちょっと自分の話をさせていただきますと
へ
42歳なんですけれどもちょっとこれまで生きてきてターニングポイントが何回かあり
ました
そのターニングポイントを遡って考えてみると結構な確率で何か
自分が最初に建てたボールとか仮説プロセスみたいなことがなんか決定段階では覆って
いたりするんですよね
重要なターニングポイント
ってことです例えばこんな偉そうなことを今日お話ししてるんですけれども
あの今の会社を決めたのもですね学生時代に何気なくあった教授の何気ない一言が
きっかけだったんですねそれまでは自分次週
百花亭に染めようなんて1ミリたりともへと思ってませんでした
初志貫徹とかその自分のその思ったことをやり遂げるってとっても素晴らしいことだと
思うんですけれども
その素晴らしい出会いのために判断の余白を残しておくことってとても重要なことだと
思いませんか
これってまあ買い物に限らずその人生全般についてももしかしてあげるかも知れません
よね
まあ陳腐な表現になりますけれども情報があふれる今
ただ自分が決めてるんだか決めさせられてるんだかわからないっていう中でやっぱり
その相対した
この生のみずみずしいそのリアルの中で最終的にシールを見つけていくっていうの
はとっても大事だなと思っていますもしかしたらもしかしたら私が勤めている百貨店
っていうのはそんな価値を皆さんに提供できるかもしれません
私が勤めているのは日本橋三越えっといってですね三越の本邸なんですけれども
百貨店です百貨店というのは百科
100は数字ですけれども彼というのはしなものなんですね
衣食住にわたってまぁいろんなものが扱われているよっていうことを表した言葉なん
ですけれども
三越はですね江戸時代に創業いたしまして
1904年にデパートメントストアせ
音源というのを行いましたまあデパートメントストアは英語なんでまぁお手本が海外に
あったわけなんですけれども
海外では様はいろんな文化ですよね department なんでうん化したものを
一つの店舗で扱っているよっていう department スタート入っていて
まあその全体としてみるとたくさんのものが使っているので
日本では百貨店という言葉が食べられたんじゃないかなというふうに言うと思ってい
ます
できた当時はですねまだものがそれほどまあ要は
行き渡ってない時代で百貨店はものを通じて
ものをただ売るだけではなくてその先にある
幸せで新しい楽しい暮らし方を提案していました
私はそんな会社に勤めで19年になるんですけれども今でもビジネスを成立させつつ
この変わり続ける生活者の場合は気持ちに皇帝あの
応えられるようななんか事って何だろうっていうのを日々考えていますでそんな私が
今日
申し上げたいのはもしかしは百貨店
園庭もものをたくさん並べてえええ
いる場所じゃないかもしれないなってもう薄々ちょっと思っています
でものは並べるんですけれどももう強調ポイントがそこじゃないんじゃないかっていう
ことなんですね
じゃあどこがじゃあ百貨店としてやるべきなのかというとやはり
道との出会いを提供すること
とだと思っていますでなんでミッションを狙いを提供するのかというとそれは皆さん
いらっしゃっていただいた方々に世界の認識を広げていただきたいからです
認識世界って認識が全てだと思うんですよね
存在していても認識していなければその人にとってそれって良い意味を持たないと思い
ます
でその世界うの認識を広げるためには予測不可能な
り愛が必要で百貨店で実はそんな出会い分ですね
提供できる機能が結構あるんですね
一つ
販売員が5000人います約5000いますちょっとした村ですよね
で眉は百花亭なんでいらっしゃるところじゃない方も大体の広さから見たイメージ
できると思うんですけども
すごい人口密度なんですねもうこれだけでなんか
セレンディピティが生まれるような僕は気がするんですけれどもこの5000人は
単なる5000人じゃないんです
それぞれに弾いデータ分野とか専門分野を持っていて例えば
お客様に合ったカラーを提案できる人ですとか
例えば洋服のフィット感号こうなんというでしょうかね見る専門の人ですとか
あと野菜ソムリエなんていいと思います
で彼ら彼女らが皆さんお客様と対話をして似合う色だったりとか
に合う合うサイズであったりとか主な食べ物とか
その美味しい食べ方なんていうのを終え教えてくれるんですね
てえっと知ってる人と気の置けない友人とか著名人のレコメンデーションって最強じゃ
ないですか
えっとまぁ実際にですねまぁこういう彼等彼女だと話をしてみて
信頼が置けそうだったらぜひですね乗っかっていただきたいんですよね
もしかしたらそこで
いらっしゃる前はこれを買おうかなって思っていたこととか
この品物ってまぁこんな機能だろうって思っていたことが軽やかにもしかしたら裏切ら
れる意味ですよ
かもしれません
って昨日の2つ目としてですねえっとを言いたいのはですね
ひゃっかてんてー中に自由に過ごせるスペースが結構あるんですね
屋上とか
これは吹き抜けなんですけれどもちょっと自由にくつろげるスペースですとか
あと日本橋三越にはパイプオルガン
ってもありますこれは実際にえーっと一日を限って演奏をされてたりします
で都心の建物で入場料も払わず
まあいいある意味で好き勝手できる過ごせる建物ってそんなないんですよねここでの私
のおすすめは
ぜひですね急いで買わないでゆっくりと過ごす
時間を楽しんでほしいんですよね
出会い色々比較をしてみたいですとか疲れたらカフェに入ってみたいですとか
あとは同じようにいらっしゃっているお客様をちょっとへ観察して参考にしてみたりと
かなんかもうそれだけであの満足度というか
買い物上がるような気がしませんでしょうか
やっぱり我々て今その決められた時間の中にどれだけのものを詰め込んで効率を上げて
生産性を上げていこうかっていうことに
要はあの血道を上げていると思うんですねこれ私もそうなんですけれども
ゴールが決まればそこの最短距離のえっプロセスを描かなきゃいけないほどの驚愕関連
なんですけども
百貨店と来た時ぐらいはその強迫観念からですね解き放っていただいてぜひですね
買い物というか過ごすっていう時間を楽しんでいただきたいなと思います
で車へと出た後とで皆さんの世界の認識が1ミリでも広がっていることこれが百貨店が
提供できる新しい頭です
でその時に買っていただくか買っていただかないとかっていうのはあくまでも結果の話
であって
私は重要だと思っているのはそういう体験を提供することだと思うんですね
もしかしたら昔もそうだったかもしれません
ものが時代ない時代にできた百貨店はもの後
並べて買っていただくことを通じて豊かで楽しく幸せな新しい生活を得体をしていまし
た
ものにあふれる時代そのスピリッツを生かして百貨店がやるべきことっていうのが
未知との出合いだと思っています3種の出会いは皆さんの世界をいくばくか広げてそれ
が結局は楽しい生活に繋がると思うんですね
ものがたくさんある百貨店からいろんな道の出会いを提供することが可能なお店
先端技術ですとか政治だけが世界を変えるんじゃないと思います百貨店だって世界を
変えられると思いますぜひですね次のお休みには百貨店にいらっしゃってはいかが
でしょうかありがとうございました
[拍手]